one surprising aspect of Wednesday has
some fans flocking to social media to
fawn over star Jenna Ortega it is under
a deadpan demeanor or the character's
sadistic impulses it's pure talent since
cartoonist Charles Adams introduced his
Addams family cartoons in the late 1930s
the Beloved Oddball family has been
adapted into live action on several
occasions first came the 1964 television
series which ran for 64 episodes over
two seasons despite its short run the
series did an excellent job of bringing
the Adams Clan into mainstream pop
culture and the original cast returned
for a 1977 TV movie director Barry
sonafeld built upon this groundwork in
1991 with his feature film The Addams
Family which was followed by a 1993
sequel Adams Family Values for many fans
the undeniable standout to both features
was Christina ricci's take on Wednesday
Adams Gomez and morticia's stoic Twisted
daughter became a hit with moviegoers
making Wednesday one of the most popular
members of the family
I'm not perky it's a natural progression
then to Netflix's Wednesday a show all
about the character coming of age and
solving a deadly mystery that has
plagued her family for years Wednesday
premiered on Netflix on November 23 2022
introducing subscribers to Jenna
Ortega's version of The Beloved
character for the most part audiences
seem impressed with what she has to
offer is Wednesday with one aspect in
particular really wowing them not long
after Wednesday arrived on Netflix fans
flocked to social media to express their
adoration for Jenna Ortega's cello
performances on the show One tweeted
first episode of Wednesday Netflix was
really good only issue is that I was
hoping I could hear Jenna Play The Cello
more another commented I get chills
whenever I see and listen to Wednesday
playing the cello scenes fans love of
the cello scenes inevitably led to
questions about where to find more when
asked Jenna Ortega's cello and Wednesday
absolutely knocked my socks off does
anyone know where to find her almost
solo cello performance she plays in
episode 1 another fan tweeted that they
loved the symbolism behind one of
Wednesday's cello performances Wednesday
playing cello while the statue is
burning down his poetic Cinema though
some fans took to social media to praise
the show's soundtrack as a whole many
tweeted requests for more scenes of
Ortega showing off her musical Talent
one wrote I needed more scenes of her
playing the cello I got chills both
times as if her performances on the show
weren't impressive enough it turns out
that Ortega had no cello experience
going into the Netflix series in an
interview with wired Ortega revealed
that she learned to play the cellos
specifically for Wednesday she hasn't
picked the instrument up much since
filming wrapped because she's been busy
with other projects but it's clearly
something she has a great appreciation
for in hindsight I have immense respect
for anybody who plays a cello I think
it's such a delightful instrument fans
once again hurled praise at Ortega when
they found out the Wednesday Star had no
prior experience with the instrument one
wrote the fact that Jenna Ortega
actually started practicing the cello in
real life for this role just really
shows the commitment and dedication
another tweeted as a cellist I am so
proud that Jenna took cello lessons to
make it look somewhat believable
honestly love these scenes another
Twitter user praised the Wednesday
creative team for making the scenes as
musically authentic as possible saying
Wednesday had some of the most effective
fake cello plane I've seen in a long
time that stuff usually takes me out of
a scene so fast but I was really
impressed they definitely had someone on
set who knew what they were doing same
Tweeter hypothesized that a professional
must have played during the close-up
shots
[Music]